what are they they're called SAR  study analyzed reprogram they learn like  us identify why are we here Mills I only  know that you were requested you why are  you here you know where we go  it's an exercise let's move I understand  you're super tech Mills all a bunch of  caveman huh not all of you what's going  on  this is just part of the training right  they had us but while she was there  they let us walk why identify did you  bring these Marines here yes my god some  programmers screwed up someone no  screw-ups aren't so efficient  those are our positions you're copying  us let me go  Oh  there's a leader we need to find it  identify  I'm 25  125  human  you